now we can do it and here we go
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
back
to your favorite podcast you know what
it's called
[Applause]
[Music]
and uh this today's guest uh one of my
favorite people in the whole wide world
one of my best friends one of the
funniest comics in the world mr ian
edwards what's up y'all never met him
before in my life
[Music]
do you want to get on the singing mic
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
all right we did it you you can take
your headphones off if you want or we
can keep them on what you want to do
we'll see you we'll see how he's feeling
let's see how it feels all right so here
we go uh
with uh mr ian edwards uh got you got i
know you the big thing you got coming on
is you got the the special coming out
oh yeah uh it's gonna be on uh comedy
central right
what's the name of it it's called ian
talk it's called ian talk
better than the ted talk uh because it's
more real um
real ted talk ideas not worthless
spreading
look at that and that's how we do it um
so yeah i've known you a long ass time
like we've known each other since like
actually you know i remember the first
time i met you it was for real yeah it
was we was doing um
a uh remember i met ahmed and i we had
that show out in uh
temptation yeah that was the first time
we actually like
you know interacted with each other
because that was so long ago
yeah he was a master at like get getting
places to like give comics money to you
know that didn't deserve that amount
yeah because that thing like i got like
a thousand years to drive to orange
county
it was the first that was like in the
first couple of months of that where
people were getting a thousand dollars
these people getting ripped off but i'm
not going to tell them
i'll take the thousands i know i know i
just did that in saudi arabia
oh no i missed i missed robbing those
people with
i know we were supposed to go that just
didn't work out yeah yeah so i remember
i saw you back then
um you had that and then you like that
at that time too that was when the shark
joke was that it was like you know
everybody was
talking about that right right yeah you
know and so then and then after that i
don't know when we just really started
just hanging out
because i think you started coming to
the store
yeah that was like 2005-ish six 2006.
and then you sit in the back and
complain what's wrong with this guy
what do you mean you mean finally a
kindred spirit that's what you really
mean i mean you know
i feel like i have more quality
complaints
oh my god no no but you're gonna blast
me on my uncle
yeah yeah but i think i think
you were complaining back then
out of more insecurity and then like it
took like a year
or so for you to become more secure and
more cemented
as a as a comic and then like you know
you'd blow me away and i'd be like oh
[ __ ] man this [ __ ] is good
yeah yeah i appreciate it that's like
all right i gotta talk to him
i don't want to i know i think it's
funny i think i think that's a
do you think that that's um a product of
like the environment at the comedy store
maybe i mean did you feel like you made
a turn at some point
yes for sure and why did you make that
turn and how
well i feel like just like the struggle
at the comedy store you're trying to get
spots you tr you know
you're constantly looking at the lineup
you're wondering how to get into that
prime
spot i don't even do all that you know
but at the time you know i didn't i
didn't know at the time then
then it just got to a point where i was
like i don't give a [ __ ] anymore right
and it was like
you know forget i don't need this place
and as soon as that turn happened
because i was doing other things right
and then that's when it just opened up
at the comedy store
i know some people at the store were
like oh he has sound effects and stuff
like that and i'm like what's wrong with
that
you know what i mean i was like i wish i
could i like that's a scalability a
skill set
and then people who call themselves like
cerebral comics
would like [ __ ] on that and then like if
you did anything
animated they just say you weren't a
comic
or you're you're up to some witchcraft
or a trickery yeah yeah yeah
but richard pryor did voices characters
he could do so many things he could make
it sound like he's stepping on a twig on
the floor
so i'm not gonna like see you have like
similar abilities and like [ __ ] on you
so i got as i i i hey guys
you go back and forth with some guys you
say that now like how is that even a
point
yeah i know it's a weird thing it's like
i had to like not worry about that kind
of stuff
because doc used to tell me how people
would talk [ __ ] about me
you know throw him under the bus but
he'd be like i would drive up in the
parking lot he'd be like yo man
they they don't respect you they're over
here [ __ ] on you so you would tell
me about everybody even people that i
consider my friends right
like you tell you he told you about when
i said yeah everybody but he would be
like yeah
whoever it was but it was like but i
never really worried about it because i
always thought the way you thought about
it i was like this is just
how i am if i'm gonna let people try to
change me because i'm not gonna be a
comic like that because i appreciate
like for instance you are very sorry
you're very cerebral comic you're
low-key you have a certain type of
energy
right that's like low high energy so
you're very sexual
oh boy what this ladies listening bro
i don't know maybe there's ladies
listening now
sorry guys oh you're so stupid
thank you and then like you know you got
the um you know so you have that so i
when i saw what you do i was like well i
can't do what he does i'm not gonna try
to do that
i wish i could do more and i think
as time goes on like i'm developing into
more so it's not just cerebral like yeah
like i find in my places where i can be
animated or
looser that's always funny to me too
when i watch you i was like look at ian
doing act outs
would you act out to always be like real
like in my head it's a huge yeah yeah to
the audience
he moved yeah your head you're doing a
backflip yeah yeah everybody else is
like he just moved from one spot to the
other but uh
no but somersault in my head yeah but i
do think that that
um the comedy store feeds the beast you
know of insecurities and all those
things and if you could fight past all
those things
and then if you get across the other
side then you're just who you are you
know what i mean
so i mean i don't like when mitzi was
alive right
wasn't the whole idea to prove to her
that you were
what you did was good or whatever you
know now it's like the
the the the ghost of her is in all the
comics
well when i got there it was like so
you're getting
i was getting spots after midnight so my
goal was to
perform so good at after midnight that i
just keep on sliding down
the lineup to get better spots but then
you get down
the line up i mean well because say
yeah yeah i guess i guess the later
times are down yeah yeah so so it's like
midnight and
after it's down and so it's what 9 30
yeah
yeah it starts at nine so the good spot
is so the good the first good spot is 9
30
right and the last good spot is probably
11 30. 11 30. so yeah i get like after
11 30 and [ __ ] and
so i try to work my way and like jam in
some tens and
10 30s and like some 11s you know and
do that and and i did do that that then
then the club got poplin and
a lot of like tommy left the old booker
and then they brought him back a bunch
of uh
comics that have a lot of clout and who
are funny
and so then you go back down yeah man
but but
my my goal was always never to waste the
spot
like work on some material yeah and get
better
it's like it might be the only thing i
have to do that day as a comic if i'm
not writing on the show
right right so it's like you gotta make
use of that spot
i remember cursing out this one comic
and it
sean halpin because he had a spot before
me
and he went up and he's like yeah you
you guys are dead
and i would do a joke could i could kind
of half work because he kind of half did
it
and it's like yeah this show's over
you've been here a long time
you're beat up and he keep on repeating
that mantra
until he got upstaged so the crowd was
like yeah yeah right
so then when we got upstairs hey man i'm
next and you just told the crowd
that they're done and then after me
there's four or five other comics you
can't do that [ __ ] yeah
if you are gonna mail it in then you
just mail it in or don't go on
but hey man there's other comments gonna
go on after you now
you've just convinced them that the
night is over
yeah so so me i was going up there to do
work and i did do pudding work and they
did laugh
you know what i mean you know what i
mean he did and he did like say you're
right you know
i do find that the comedy i've done i've
i've done that too to be honest yeah
i've had like a bad like
i one day i just like just was crazy it
was like friday night and i just like
lost my mind on stage
yelling at some girl and we were just
going back at it and then i remember
steve trevino was on after me
and it just turned into a whole thing
you know bobby called me he was like you
can't do that on a friday
you know what i mean and you know that
steve was mad at me and i was like ah
[ __ ] okay then i was like all right but
i find at the comedy store now what's
hard is the fact that like it's now a
show it's not a workout room anymore
you know i still do it i still work out
i know like the people have been there
like a
number of years but it's like there is
this little bit of like
sometimes you come in here it's like
goddamn it's tuesday why is this place
packed
yeah looking for a show i'm trying to
work some [ __ ] out i mean it did
frustrate me a little bit
but then i started like hey i'm not
doing bars
so this is my rough spot for the week
this is the bar
yeah and it'll help me keep my edge so
try the new [ __ ] and take the l's when
they come
because you're gonna go home you're
going to listen to the set you're going
to figure out
what went wrong what went right and
you're going to fix it and enhance the
parts that went right
and don't take the sets personal it's
it's a small part of a bigger picture
you tape every set
yeah especially since the special before
i used to tape them and not listen to
them yeah
yeah so i've done that i got a bunch of
sets on youtube make you work right yeah
this special makes you work
it's the same thing because you're like
you used everything yeah and now
people are gonna it's gonna air people
are gonna come see you and you don't
wanna be
they're like i thought that guy was
funny yeah yeah so i had some i
headlined in
uh atlanta at laughing skull
like two three weeks ago and i did the
best
mediocre set that i could because i only
had like 20 minutes of new
material use some old material and tried
some brand new new material
right and just trying to get my weight
back up but yeah
it's it's it's feeling better now i'm
getting this new mate it's just the
process you go to when you're getting
new material together
i know that's i mean that's the hardest
thing but it just feels good
i actually like that process like the
working through it you know
you have this idea and then like the
first time you kind of like test it out
on stage
and if it does well you're kind of like
oh i'm on to something right here
yeah and then like being on to something
yeah yeah but what if what i wasn't
doing before was like what you do
is like putting in the work you know
it's something that i've noticed like
once since i because you remember i was
doing the same thing because i couldn't
even go out of town
right to do my special i had to do like
you know ontario brea the belly room and
i was
so i was like really working and i was
like oh i really got the best out of
myself
yeah but i see like y'all you do it
regularly like neil brennan and people
like that they're always got their
little notebooks and i was doing their
thing and i
recently i've been like why am i not
doing that right just relying so much on
just being a fighter instead of punching
us in the face when you see us with our
notebooks in the hallway
jesus but see i had the same dumb
attitude how somebody would have about
me doing sound effects or something i'd
be like look at y'all with your
notebooks
i just i just look weird because i don't
use a notebook i got my old
cell phone that's not connected anymore
i just use it as a remote control
as a recorder oh really and then i use
my and i have my new phone
with the notes written on the phone
because i'm not going to handle it i
don't waste
so you put two phones down on the stool
you look like you got a whole phone
yeah yeah you're like this [ __ ] doing
with two phones one of them ain't even
on
they don't know that yeah they don't
know that he's like this [ __ ] got two
phones
or if there's a phone on the thing and
then one is in my pocket some people
think it's my dick
because it's like that we know that's
not his phone cause his phone he just
put it on the street all right
so what's that in his pants what's that
square dickie guys
well one of my favorite things about you
is how is how uh you know
how old school you are like what i mean
young bro yeah i'm not saying you old i
didn't say he was old i said
nobody actually knows how old ian is i
think we all want to
i think the trick is we all want to like
get get together
and like say ian we sending you on a
trip and we got to buy the ticket so we
can get your pack
get your id don't don't worry i got
something for that
it's been tried before oh really yeah
please around everything
no but you also like ian don't want to
like he don't want to he don't want to
do online banking
he don't want to use apps
why is that because people are getting
gut here we go
who's getting got people are getting got
government cities are being held ransom
like even what
what's uh city or i think baltimore
got hacked oh the whole city of
baltimore yeah yeah yeah like and then
they held
their ransom some hospitals medical
records
i just the the less you just want to be
off the grid
now i want to be off the grid because
you need the grid but
like at good precaution if there's less
access for somebody to get at you then
to me that's the
ultimate protection right yeah i like
that wait i got to turn this fan
off because it's making my brick wall
move
what type of brick is this
it's moving brick y'all so now everybody
knows this
it's not a real brick
i got my new tree yeah i know you got
the yeah i'm like i'm experimenting like
like hell today i got the tree right
here
i turned the fan on cause sometimes it
gets hot so i had to turn it off because
i saw my i didn't want my brick wall
looking like it was like people gonna be
like is the wall moving or am i
high yeah yeah edibles that i take yeah
they're all the edibles that i take
so i know you sit between one fern
so i know you uh you're originally from
new york or did were you born in jamaica
or were you rich
are you i was born in england and then
lived there until i was like look at the
way you're looking at me you didn't know
this i didn't notice
you knew this no i didn't know this is
why i like having a podcast
i'm like ian is literally like you know
i say people my best friend
ian is literally one of my best friends
like like in the tops you know what i
mean and i didn't know you were born in
england never listen
this explains so much why are you such a
boozy thing
from the old country i get it now it's
hilarious
so yeah i was born in england lived
there until i was like nine and then we
moved to jamaica until nine
yeah was your dad in the military or
something no no he's just
a jamaican guy just trying to find some
work
so he was a country that colonized his
country
wait wait did was he already married
when he when he was got to
do or did he meet your mom in in london
i don't know our parents don't tell us
that type of [ __ ]
oh that's true [ __ ] yeah that was a boy
because i'm surprised he you know you
don't have a white mom
nah not this time jamaica jamaican dude
in london that's like
fresh pickings no i got he got a
jamaican one yeah yeah
so so you guys so you're nine years old
then you moved to
to jamaica yeah oh you oh you went from
england to jamaica yeah yeah damn
yeah to go home for them yeah to get rid
of all the booziness
they were like this he's too entitled we
need to take him to the home country
yeah so how long did you live in jamaica
till it was like 17 oh [ __ ]
did you know in jamaica that you wanted
to be a comic nah no idea
um i just i didn't know i just wanted to
graduate to america and have a chance
how was it like her being going to high
school in jamaica
it was fun but like you could tell
that there was limits to living
in the island you know what i mean like
yeah like like i didn't even know what i
wanted to do
but like jobs were scarce
especially if you wanted to like elevate
to a certain
level financially you just felt like
there was a cap it was a cap
yeah because sometimes there's
corruption and [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying so
i was like [ __ ] my i aspired
was so broken jamaica aspired to live in
the projects in america
that was you wanted to upgrade to the
new york project
you got an elevator that don't work this
is nice
it's beautiful so then
so you're saving nothing but a bunch of
rich [ __ ] around
not even knowing that this is like yeah
i mean it's i mean
there's opportunity anytime there's
opportunity and this potential
right it's better did your whole family
move to new york or was it just
the whole family oh the whole family it
was like okay so london jamaica
what a what a stopover yeah that's a
major like
third world stopover yeah but it was fun
man it was a great
growing up there learned a lot of things
uh it helped make me
who i am you know what i mean like it
just
taught me so many great lessons and
like like what give me an example of a
lesson you learned from jamaica
i think like so you know how long i've
been doing stand up right
and i think at least 42 years yeah
so some comics if they're not
like more famous than i am right now
if and i'm i'm just i'm just saying more
famous than i am right now or
have accomplished more right
they'd be really frustrated you know
what i mean
to the point that because you some
people are it's tough for them to not
look at what other people have
and when they start and compare and
compare you know
to me it's like you know this is
good i'm i've been happy either way
yeah you know what i mean because
there's been times when i've had
way less and didn't even expect this
much
you know what i mean so i'm like yeah
i'm fine
and this is weird because this this is
the kind of business that you're always
around someone who
either has a lot or you are around
people that like
have it's just what you have and then
all of a sudden they have
you know you know you're like pow right
then you look at that and you go what am
i not doing and you can't be like that
at all
you can't be like that yeah because it
drives you crazy it'll drive you crazy
and it'll ruin the good time that you
should be having
on the climb yeah yeah on the climb so
yeah i've always
enjoyed the journey you know i don't
know what told me to tell myself that
like enjoy the journeys like what are
you gonna do have fun
when you make it you that's so much
might be so much time you missed
yeah so i just enjoy it all the time all
the times we go to the diner yeah
yeah and talk and laugh those aren't and
going there to intentionally have
fun and break bread with friends and
[ __ ] and that
and if i walk out that diner get hit by
a car
i was laughing right before that right i
know exactly what you're saying that's
great
i like that mentality i mean it's like
why not have fun while we're doing this
yeah i mean and that's
i if i look back on some of the good
times i've had in comedy it really is
just hanging out
like you know like we go out to eat with
jerrod or like you know hanging out with
chris
yeah all the different groups of
different people even with la noche and
fahim
and just you know just well what i like
about our core group of those type of
guys
is that like bobby for instance like
because like bobby and chris and like
they're
they're still they're not they're not
different like i've seen chris go from
like you know when he was just doing
belly room spots and going to the haha
to like the ginormous comic that he is
and i don't see that much of a
difference in his personality no he's
actually gotten
even better not that he was bad before
but he's just really generous yeah
yeah yeah so i like that but and then we
and we're seeing this happen to other
people they look at like
theo you know yeah like theo's like you
know he's gonna get like a
real rollercoaster uphill but it's good
to see like that
not everybody stays grounded though i
mean i'm not gonna be come on
how are you gonna get me on here bro oh
that's right i forgot we're talking
about
we're talking to ian billboard edwards
right here everybody yeah he got a bunch
of how many
how many billboards around l.a listen
there's only 43.
all right a monster they've created a
[ __ ]
if it was 44 and then maybe you'd have
to talk to my people to get me on here
is this
it's one sort of moment yeah you know
somebody's big when they have a po
when i have to go through their
assistant or their publicist to come on
my podcast yeah and it's not them
pretending to be their assistant yes
yeah yeah i had romney on it i didn't
even talk to him until the day he showed
up that's hilarious yeah this
[ __ ] i talked i told him in the
pocket i said
yo dude what's up with you can't text me
yourself
you know but that's like i know so we're
enjoying the journey so i guess so
that's a good jamaican lesson i guess
yeah yeah like you know
coming from nothing and then like
realizing that enjoy every ever
i told you i inspired to live like when
i was growing up in jamaica i like want
like
two pairs of shoes so when i saw
american
black people even though they have a
right to complain and have gripes
like it took me a while to understand
like
oh you got like a pair of shoes for
every day
you made it your feet made it at least
yeah these ain't
i got monday through wednesday i got
school shoes
and some shoes to wear at church that's
it damn yeah
don't get caught in your church shoes in
the middle of the week
your mom will get mad yeah so you're so
now you're 17
in in new york and then did you so you
hadn't graduated high school yet or you
did you graduated
i did graduate because they have school
is different yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you have you graduate and then then
there's these
other tests that you can stay in school
for
you can go to college or you can just
take the the a levels
and then go to university did you have
did you plan to go to college is that
what you wanted
no by the time everything worked out i
finished high school
and then stayed for one year of the
a-level studies
in jamaica and my brother
older brother my older sister and my
father
came here with my mother oh and they
got [ __ ] together for a year and they
got a house in
long island and then me and my sister
came out
a year later and moved in with them into
the house oh god so instead of all of us
being in my mom's one bedroom apartment
in queens in jamaica
so they did that and then when you got
here
it was cold yeah i showed that i'm sure
that was different
it might not even be that cold i'm just
so used to being yeah
like the jamaican winner is 90. so jesus
jacket weather was like 85 years i was
like we gotta get a coach
it's hot cold out here so when did uh
so you didn't go to school when you came
what what i went to high school
oh so you had to because yeah it was an
equivalent right yeah they
it's it's actually more than equivalent
jamaica's like
uh high school is like harder than
americans
right right but especially in certain
areas yeah but because they feel like
you come from an island and it's not
like
we're like using like the english in
jamaica we're using like the english
standards because it's standard yeah of
teaching and learning because
you know you know we're a former college
right just like belize
yeah my family yeah yeah there you go
yeah i'm fantastic i i know exactly what
you're saying
yeah that's why i have family from
jamaica it's like it's like they're both
they're cousins they got that same you
know
what i tell you about that
he knows that that's about jamaica
welcome to the podcast ian edwards
so you um all right so when did you want
to win well then when i came here
i thought i was smart oh genius and like
well especially in high school yeah it
was like we
already did this it's killing them in
high school and you were already older
yeah you're stupid no i wasn't i mean i
guess
like because they made you did they make
you do your senior year again
like i came in the middle so i did
i did do the senior year but yeah
oh i got you yeah when when was uh
when was comedy the thing like
early 20s yeah yeah like early 20s i
wasn't thinking about
comedy i was like i just wanted to get a
job
where you could make like my
my next-door neighbor they their my
their father
was making like fifty thousand a year i
heard i need i need to get it oh you was
like i got fifty thousand
look at this so that's what you got to
make
to be clear yeah
yeah that's what you gotta make to be
clear he's got two kids
nice backyard you know he was like this
is it
so you just gotta do and then you stand
in front of that house like this is a
palace yeah
i was like looking at people's like that
guy's a mailman he got medical benefits
maybe job on the railroad or just fine
go to go to college figure out a job i
was going to be like uh
uh this is dumb i was watching general
hospital
tv she did it yeah it's pretty dumb and
there was a guy on there he was a
physical therapist
and he was sleeping with all the women
in town
and it looked like he had it made
financially so i was like i want to be
that
you look at that general hospital yeah
are you like oh
i need you i need to go into physical
therapy because it feels all right so
you're learning something you're almost
a doctor so it's almost
you know it's
yeah you know what i'm saying so it's
going to be a supply
of injured people but the funny thing is
the underlying of this whole thing was
still
and he get a lot of [ __ ] and that too
you know
yeah [ __ ] so then when so then you're
like
still flandering around obviously
because i know how i remember my early
20s just trying to figure out what do i
want to do
i didn't know what i wanted i even tried
comedy and still and it was like my
early 20s
yeah i'm from l.a but i was like i i
don't know how to do this
i don't know where to go who did you
know i had too many bad experiences so i
didn't you know
i didn't really do comedy until i was
30. right you know but like you i mean
to
you know you're in new york but that's
probably easier and not that it's easier
there's just more opportunity to do
stand-up in new york well i think there
kind of was back then this is before now
young comics i feel bad for them
they're already broke and i i remember
being broke
and putting gas in the car to get to
mike's and pay
tolls and all that stuff just to oh [ __ ]
that's right right
damn you know and you should think
bought me a bunch of comics
sometimes there's one comic he had
someone he was like an architect but he
was our
age he had his [ __ ] financially he had
his own apartment in queens
that's the dream tourists for taurus and
he used to jump in john's car and drive
to gigs and he used to pay the towing be
in the back
and you just never access for money so
that helped us oh sure
and what was what was what was your club
in uh what was like the the your go-to
well
when you first governors was the first
one but they only had an open mic
either once or twice a week so then you
have to go then add one
a club in like yonkers so you gotta pay
toll for that [ __ ] you know saying you
have to get by gas
put a toll for that [ __ ] and there was
one in queens
there's like jimmy's comedy alley and we
just
would just all meet up at somewhere
there was chuckles so chuckles was local
too
yeah now were you doing were you doing
black rooms back then nah i started out
in like white rooms
yeah those were the ones that were there
and then
then some black rooms came up and i
started doing that so i had to learn
comedy all over again yeah i could tell
because you you have a different pacing
and style
like white comedy is different and then
you have to do
like oh these jokes don't work in a
black room based on the way they're
booing me
so were you getting moved did you get
boobs yeah yeah yeah black rooms are
like
yeah it's like they're like we don't
take the observational [ __ ]
it's got to be relatable and then the
thing that was also
kind of like i had to figure out about
black rooms like
when i hung out with black comics and
they would say
stuff to the audience the artist like
yeah yeah we remember that
i'm like oh [ __ ] i didn't even grow up
here so they have a wealth
right of growing up american black
and they can relate to this audience and
i'm like
i'm just learning black american culture
right so i'm like
not only now i got to figure out black
american culture so i can relate to
people or figure out
a way sometimes you try to fake it
you're just
just so many different what you do so do
this thing
wrong so many ways until you figure out
the right way to do it did you have an
accent at the time
yeah and then i then i came up with
talking about being jamaican
right right so then that helped yeah and
that would kill in the in the black room
yeah yeah for sure you know i have
something i noticed like having family
from
you know belize jamaica and when they
would come to the united states
there was like a little bit of a rift
between people from those places
and black americans yeah because it
wasn't the same experience like
like like we didn't hate white people
in the same way that amer black
americans did did your family have that
kind of thing going on
no i don't we we didn't it was more like
i don't mean that everybody hates black
white people i'm just saying you know
this kind of
it was a different struggle you know and
so they they didn't always feel the same
way about it
well i think when like jamaican people
like how do i put this like i tell
other people like we used to get into
fights with the yankees that's what we
used to call american black
new yorkers because
we're a small group
from a different place and we land in
their place
and like it's like
i wouldn't even say the term bullying
but it's like you just
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna [ __ ]
with these guys yeah but then jamaican
people
are like some of the boldest brashes
[ __ ] and like oh yeah
bring it all ten thousand of you
bring it and then they're like ian
sean these ten thousand fools wanna
fight us i'm like
they're not fool we sound like the fools
yeah i don't know where you learned math
but
yeah but i know i always felt like i
think that poli people from belize in
jamaica felt differently about their
culture because they were allowed to
have a culture i mean those these are
both slave ports
right you know both slave ports they got
their independence
and then then a culture was formed and
then
people in the united states you know
african americans black americans
whatever the term we're using this
this you know this decade you know they
they
feel like robbed of of their original
culture
so i just think that that was part of
the part of the
the rift yeah there definitely was a
riff but i don't know
i don't know because we were different
than them and people always
with differences always don't trust the
people who
come in it's true after you know and it
could be
the cultural thing like you were saying
there was definitely like
and and then there were moments when we
did get along
but then if there was a reason for beef
then they would just take it all of a
sudden you become jamaican
jamaicans banana boat all that [ __ ] yeah
and they have their slurs for us
yeah to like put us down and then you
know yeah
well you say yeah yeah you know so then
you
so that's interesting that you so then
like that that trying to come up in the
black
comedy world being like oh i don't know
the black references
the american black references so you had
to have your own thing so you're doing
the jamaican thing and then
but it would work for the black because
then by then new york
had been infiltrated by a lot of
jamaicans
so then everybody kind of grew up with
some and knew yeah and been to reggae
clubs had jamaican food so then
instead of trying to be american the
more jamaican
i was on stage that helped me
but then that wouldn't necessarily
transfer to a white club
right so then i have to kind of figure
out something now what do i do
for everybody so this is a lot of back
and forth yeah and trials and figuring
stuff out and then becoming more
american at the time and figuring out a
way
so that's why i don't have any jamaican
jokes because then it became limiting
because if i
went out of new york i went to some
places even when there were black people
there like in philly
they didn't have any jamaicans the time
i did that show opened up with those
jamaican jokes in philly
they just booed me off the stage yeah so
you got a lot of booing going on in the
in early ian that this is why before
billboard edwards
43 of them everybody 40 43 baby
43 billboards around their lane check
them out
but yeah i earned those billboards
wait a minute should be more anyway
listen they uh
like that's why sometimes like like the
other day i put a sketch up
on my instagram mm-hmm and then
it was about the ruiz fight when he beat
anthony joshua
right ruiz is a and i in my post i gave
a clown ruiz but i gave him his props in
the
the caption another like
uh instagram posted it and reposted it
with their own caption
and then somebody's like [ __ ] on me
like
this guy's not funny blah blah blah you
think that then it's like hey
like the people who come at me on
instagram or any of us
if you think you're one lines or two
lines of insults
it's gonna stop me from thinking i'm
funny
right it's like you're wasting your time
like
listen i didn't listen to a thousand
people born me
yeah when i wasn't funny
so you think for real now that there's
proof that i'm funny
that you're gonna like
say a message or comment in the comment
section and stop me
it's not you're wasting your time just
it's they're all cowards i mean when
when this uh when this airs you know
it's like i'm sure i'm gonna be live
chatting and i'm sure
even right now there's people chatting
in the chat
while we're watching this and you're
being troll [ __ ]
stop it no i i i could yeah but then
again that's probably another
lesson from from jamaica just just
taking all that stuff
yeah yeah so you're in you so you're not
you're figuring it out though i could
tell like that new york experience
you figuring it out you're you're you're
building on your act
and then like what what was jeff jam
like was that how how how many years
before that to jeff jam
uh i think i got on def jam when def jam
wasn't as popular
as it was oh there was something that
did there was this thing called
who's the host uptown comedy club tv
show i did that first
oh because i remember that yeah so i did
that and
that was a hit set that was a really
good set and then
maybe took two more years after that to
do death jam oh i can't
really remember yeah all right wow you
got to look up def jam jeff jam ian
stupid he had the [ __ ] the dredge
he was high energy i don't know what
happened to you
that's what you did in new york you
jumped on that audience and you let them
know so that they wouldn't like smell
any fear
and come at you it's the same type of
style of jokes like logic wise
yeah but yelled how i can
well i had a machete in my hand when i
was telling those jokes
[Laughter]
so then uh when did you come to when did
you come to la
because at that point now you're
established people know you you're in
that community you're
you're in the comedy community you're
also in the black comedy community yeah
i was doing it all
yeah you were doing it figured it out i
was doing black clubs white clubs
black colleges you know just you know
and
you know it had a lot of you know bad
tests but figured it out you know
you know and and then then you go but
i'd still be nervous and [ __ ] but then
there's a point hey man you're gonna
enjoy this thing or not you can't just
have fun
after you have a good set you know yeah
you got to have fun
before during and after well there's
like a
there's like a moment that you've when
you're doing comedy dead like when you
feel like it starts to work you're doing
well but then you start to go well wait
a minute
like what am i going to do with this
right you know because it's like
i'm still you know it's like i'm still
renting i'm still you know you know what
i mean that's when you like
when when did it become a rat race for
you like when did it become like i need
to like get
get at this is that when you decided to
move to la or like what was what was the
process
nah like there was one moment when
i had a girlfriend at the time or
she was my ex-girlfriend but i was
hanging out with her and her family a
lot was just like
a lot of fun in the friends in the
neighborhood right and
this is earlier on and then i'd had
friends a lot of black comics and i'd
like you
see fl you go to a comedy show and
sometimes in comedy
you could be going to a lot of shows but
not on them
and then one day hit me like i'm not on
this flyer i don't know this oh right
no no this fly this is back when they
had flies yeah and i'm not on any flyers
that's like i'm not really a comic i'm
just hanging out yeah people have seen
me do comedy
and then it's probably my fear of taking
an l
you know like like i wanted to preserve
the set that i did that was good there
in that club like months ago
uh wow yes i know exactly what you're
saying you know what i mean no risks no
change no no
nothing but then i'm like not on this
show not on this show so now like i had
to make up my mind
back then to be like all right i gotta
go to some of these shows and do a guest
spot
ask for a guest spot which they would
give you free oh you're going to do it
for free
then i'd rip and then they would book me
and i just started doing that with all
the shows and
like there was a moment day when i
thought i was doing comedy
when i wasn't right and then
i think a lot of comics make that
mistake i know i did i
seen other people do it and i was like
all right let me so from that moment
then i was like bang bang bang bang bang
and then they had this uh you traveling
around the country you're traveling
around the country yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all that all
that stuff happened so
so then when did you go from
like being like not to say that you were
just doing black shows or a black comic
but like because but back then i was
doing like around this time i'm doing
everything now
i know but like but the public
perception because of like you know you
do
you did these tv shows but when did you
transition over to like where you were
doing like
you know where where when were you
accepted to the main
what is the public perspective
perception by the way because i
sometimes
i might not be aware of it sometimes if
you give me a compliment i'll actually
break down a compliment not because i
want to hear it again well i do
but i also want to understand what
people are thinking of me well i'm just
thinking at the time you know that those
shows were big you know like
if like if you do like it's like if you
do a black show
you know all of a sudden it's like oh
you're a black comic right right you
know what i mean if you'd like you know
it's like
look at someone like gary owen i just
had him on the podcast too like gary is
like you know
you know it's like he always does black
was into black shows but
i hear i heard his story his story is
interesting of like he grew how he grew
up and the reason why he gravitated
towards you know
it wasn't like it wasn't like he was
trying to like oh that's just who he was
he's just who he was you know what i
mean this was wise black you know
all the people that influenced him in
his life were black you know those are
the ones
it was his white stepfather that was the
[ __ ] you know what i mean so he had
an interesting story so i'm saying like
but when you
think of him you think of him oh he's
that white comedy that does black rooms
right
but that's not necessarily what all that
he does so i'm saying back then it's
like
you did uptown you did def jam so it was
like oh
is he just a black comic well i always
wanted to be universal
yeah yeah so i wanted to be universal
and be able to do both because i've had
the struggles
figuring one out figuring the other one
out and then going back and
had to re-figure the other one so i said
i just want to have like one act that
just works right
yeah you know what i mean oh is that oh
that's interesting so is that when you
decided to like
you tone down the jamaican you toned out
of the energy tone it down i was like
you have to write this so both places
get it
yes and then a part of you two like just
as a black person you feel
guilty if you can't kill a black room i
do or i used to
so i was like i just wanted black people
laugh
as much as white people you know what i
mean so i just wanted to
you know even though there's more
audiences now but like everybody else is
like in the
like one they're both ends of the
spectrum everybody's in the middle
and if both ends of the spectrum get you
then everybody will get you yeah
yeah so you want to you want to you want
to do that so it's just like
thinking all right why is this funny and
then now because of hip-hop
you don't really have to like so many
white people into black culture
yeah you're not speaking another
language sometimes when you do certain
things you know
i kind of like i i always think you know
i think
for like pop culture society i always
think mtv's
trl remember that show trl yeah when it
was at its height
i think that show changed people's
perception of all this because
they had that top they had that top you
know top 10
whatever videos right but it would be
anything
right it was like whatever was popular
so it could be like you know
that's when you saw hip-hop become pop
culture right
because it was like these hip-hop songs
along with like you know taylor swift or
you know nsync would be with like snoop
dogg like so that made everybody then
these young white kids are growing up
like they just go oh this is just a
great song yeah
and this i think the same thing it
filtered over the comedy yeah and
uh yo mtv raps and just all those like
video shows it just took a while for
everything because
i noticed it now when i talk to younger
like agents and managers
in the industry they all grew up with
hip-hop
yeah and but the white people i came up
with
didn't yeah you know what i mean like
yeah
[ __ ] so when you um so what do you think
of comedy now like what
what what are your things on the state
of comedy right now on the state of
comedy
yeah like i just try i know what the
state of comedy is
what is it to you like the state of
comedy is like hey
they're into younger comics and they're
into
people who are older that have already
made it that are stars that they can
bank on and get some money from if they
they can green light a show and stuff
like that so i feel like
i'm in the middle and it's just
good to know like kind of like i'm
known but not known enough yeah so
it's like now i know what the game is
how am i going to figure out this out
and play it and it's like you have to
i like that it's in my hands
you know what i mean like yeah you back
in the day
i had to wait for my agent to be like oh
my manager to be like
all right we're gonna push you all the
way through and then sometimes you wait
and then they pick somebody else that
started after you or just
somebody else for some other reason and
push them through you just wait you wait
you wait
but now it's in your hands because of
the internet
and you can you can make yourself doing
stuff like this
doing stuff like this so i like to have
a better fight and chance
so i accept it and and you know
you know i'm coming doing your podcast
i'm gonna do a bunch of other people's
podcasts and doing the most so that
people can
know that the special is available on
friday july 12th at midnight
on comedy central just hitting places
man so that they could see it
and you know use my instagram and my
twitter
facebook and by the way if this is after
july 12th when this comes out
if it's after so make sure you go find
ian's special
on comedy central because because you'll
be able to you can i'm sure you're going
to be able to watch it on demand
on comedy central and you'll be able to
watch it on the comedy central app
and the more people that watch the
website and the website so the more
people that watch it and like it
especially on the website
that kind of stuff is key so make sure
you do that and share and
you know and all that kind of stuff yeah
especially if you like it man yeah yeah
yeah yeah don't just yeah exactly make
sure you like it
yeah i feel like yeah comedy's weird i
mean i feel like we're
because we're older right now it's like
you just have we just have a different
perspective like we're looking at the
landscape of comedy and it's just like
you know i see how often it changes and
i just go i just ride the wave
you have to like you can't be like when
i was a kid
i hated the old guy that complained and
i never want to be the old guy to
complain
because all you're going to do is
complain and the [ __ ] is going to keep
going and going and past you
anyway yeah so ride that [ __ ]
make friends with young people let them
show you which buttons to press
on the goddamn phone how do i change my
background
yeah and you know they'll help you lie
this motherfucker's this old
[ __ ] is cool
i know i never i also like if i look at
somebody and i feel like well they're
not my cup of tea
my thought never is just like oh this
person ain't funny
i just say that it's just not my cup of
tea but i look at it and i like well you
know
people seem to be enjoying this person
sometimes i say that it's not my cup of
tea but then i have to like
you just i just want to need to get the
anger out you know and then once it's
out that's right yeah
that's what you're friends for yeah yeah
that's why we
yeah you know then once we get past that
we're just like you can look at it
rationally yeah yeah
yeah gotta be you gotta trash them first
yeah yeah yeah you will
you will get trashed with ian and i for
sure
but like but yeah because i've seen i've
seen that so often and also you just
never know when it's going to happen
you know you were talking about that
middle so you have the young people who
they love to push forward even when
they're not ready
right and then these established people
but it's everybody that's in the middle
there the thing about that the fight
and the microcosm of hollywood is like
the comedy store there's all these
people that think that like
they're on the same level or like here
we are and like when something when
somebody goes
just a little bit up there's like a like
oh you're like
why am i not doing like you know that
like as if they deserve that yeah i
think i think i probably always think
i'm lower than i am
oh you think so yeah yeah that should be
more cocky
more cocky i don't know if that's
possible
i mean did you
but then it's like i don't know man
i i look back on it i wouldn't wish this
on anyone
right you know you know when you talk to
somebody and somebody's like yo man i
want to start doing comedy
i'm always like get the [ __ ] away from
me like talk to me in five years
let me just beat you up a little while
then come talk to me about what you want
how you want to get into comedy
i mean it's great if you're young or if
you have a story
you know and you figure it out and i
mean like listen there's a lot of young
we just talked about garrod
yeah oh yeah four years he got like a
number i know but he's like
that guy in physics but there's other
people you know it happens there's no
right or wrong way right there's a lot
of young people doing great yeah younger
younger comics so i don't think it's
that bad it's just i would just hate to
have to pay
five dollars to get on stage that's just
you know what i mean those are the days
man
there was places like that here there
was this like place way out in the
valley
like you just take the 101 like going
towards
a camarillo they had it was called the
oh man what was the name of this place i
forgot the name of the place but it was
like a
you know like it had it was a little
theater and you know you had to pay five
dollars at the bar to perform i mean i
just think back to that of like damn
yeah these places figured out the game
they were like these people they
we go take advantage of these dreamers
yeah exactly
like some of these places it's like the
tough thing for anybody starting an
entertainment if you're broke
is whether you're an actor or whatever
people are always
charging you to advance in your craft at
the point
where you have no money yeah and then
you feel desperate enough to
fork up your money so you can get played
a lot the worst is like when you're
trying to be a model
you know like they used to have those
those websites would be like you know
for six hundred dollars
you're gonna get your portfolio you're
gonna get you're gonna be on our website
and just like
like think of this piece of [ __ ] that
came up with that scam
right you know and i were there i don't
know if there was things like that for
comedy
they were things where it's just classes
or whatever it is like that
classes or they promise you'll meet some
agents if you take the class
oh right right there's like a showcase
and agents are going to come
at the end of the course and come to
find out that they pay those agents
casting person will be there
they're there but i don't know if
they're really looking yeah yeah
yeah and then uh that would be the thing
where
some agency would be like we saw you and
we like you
but you need headshots you have to go to
this place and take headshots it only
cost this amount of money
and an agency would be connected to the
headshot please yeah
yeah there's always different versions
of those scams
yeah when did you know that you felt
like you were making it
when did you know like you were doing
something and you were like did you we
are aware was there
some self-awareness of like oh i'm
actually i'm a working comic or i'm like
one of those guys like when
was it the tv appearances or yesterday
when you saw the 43 billboards yeah
drove around town so often
have you seen them all have you driven
around all 43 i've only seen
one oh really yeah so they just told you
that it was 43. yeah exactly
and it's 43. yeah she just picked a
number
but when did i know that like uh
i don't even sometimes i don't even
think i've made it right right to be
honest yeah yeah i know what you mean
you know and
i don't know if that sounds dominant but
i'll be like
because you see what
like people i've looked up to what
their version of making it is so i only
feel close to that
dude i know this is exactly how i feel
too so i feel like and that's
i'm talking about this on stage right
now because it's like this is the
indicative of being in la so when you're
in a place where
the spectrum of making it is
so big so you got like you know in our
field it's like
chris rock bill burr chappelle
so even someone was like i've been on a
tv series for seven years i've been on
you know what i mean
i was i was doing that stuff that ain't
it's it's still like
less than what i would even consider to
be like making it
making it so then it's funny though like
i remember
like we went to roscoe's
and like these hot girls
was like wanted your autograph and i'm
like i'm not
standing for this
hanging out this [ __ ] is going
to gloat and i was like oh [ __ ] he made
it
you know i know but it's like but i
understand you know yeah but it's just
like you just go like
for me i never like i i'm never one to
like
to like be like you know hey i'm that
dude for more golf you know because
i know that it's going to go away i knew
and you told me that too yeah i knew
that
in the middle of it i was like this is
going to go away one day and i don't
want to miss it
right you know because a lot of people
you we know people that like they miss
it
and i don't miss anything yet yeah
exactly you know so i just kind of like
i just kind of like literally feel like
i got it yeah
you know but you're doing well man you
know you know i mean people just because
you do because you're on both sides of
the
the the thing you're in front of the
camera and behind the camera yeah but
i'm about to
gamble everything on trying to get in
front of the camera and doing specials
and stuff
so it's just content i mean what do you
feel about all this like what do you
feel about that's another part of my
question about the state of comedy
what do you feel about like all of these
specials and how much comedy is out
there
well that's why i did mine the way it is
because
there's so many people have to have a
reason
besides liking you to take the time out
yeah to see your special
so i tried to do something to make it
like be special before
they saw it and to make them want to see
it
so you know like i know what it is it's
not in talk
he can't talk i know what it is i see
the landscape there's a ton of specials
what am i going to do
to make people want to see my special
but
still make it like me and not me trying
to
pretend to be somebody else that's the
hard thing man or even or even uh
not even somebody else but even a
version of yourself right or just some
weird version of yourself and i
and i think that like my first special
you know ugly truth on showtime
i feel like that was more like me that
was like material that i was doing
forever but i just did a special
i loved that material you know i just
did a special i'm just on stage doing a
thing
then the second one i think i did the
second one because
it was like i'm on show time i was on a
show it was like
they they said i could do another one
right and i so i had to like prep and
you know get it out there but like you
know but then i started to think like
they're not special anymore that's a
terrible word to use
it's just content you know like that's
my long youtube video
you know what i mean so i just putting
content out and so like this is your
first special right
yeah i mean i did an album produced by
conan before but yeah
that's a great album too that's a great
album um what's the name of that album
100
half-assed a hundred percent half-assed
you can still listen to that
uh but you yeah so like so this is your
first
special you know so but but i mean it's
isn't it it's weird though like because
if i say you're doing your first special
say
15 years ago it would be a whole
different vibe right
you know isn't that i mean i don't know
i never got one so
i don't know when you said a whole
different vibe what do you mean well i
mean uh
like the fanfare about like and and what
would be
oh you know what i mean like you'd have
a chance
for sure because of the limited amount
of specials
right did a really good one to get to
the next level yeah yeah yes
whatever that next level i think you'd
have a better chance yeah yeah yeah
it's weird to see like how like why
people pop her who pops you know
because i always think about like it's
like someone like ali wong for instance
you know
ali's been funny forever yeah she's just
a funny chick you know
and she was writing and you know you
know she was just that she just
she was in there you know and then she
got this opportunity she did that
special
it just coalesced in a way that like
like skyrocket
it's just weird how it happens right
there for some and then not for others
right you know i don't know like do you
think that there's a special out there
that you've seen do you watch specials
first
yeah i watch the ones that i can i can i
don't watch as many
as i should and there's different
reasons why i watch so many reasons why
i don't watch others
but do you think that there's a special
out there that you've seen that you go
damn i don't want
i wonder why this person didn't blow up
from this yeah that's the scary part
yeah
okay when you see a good special yeah
and the person
you asked him so how's everything going
on the road now that's the same
it's the same and you're like oh [ __ ] i
know i know
that's the scary part like you could
also you could do a really good special
and not make a dent but i understand
this is
the long game i don't understand that
after this special
i have to drop another special yeah yeah
yeah and then
it's the combination of specials when
people
like you know it just you a rolling
stone gavis moss
yes yes yes it wasn't no moss it's moss
well see i kind of feel like i felt the
same way about like you know
i thought doing tv would do the same
thing but it's like no it's like you
know
i'm on a show and it's just like okay
people are like man
people must be coming out i say not
really i mean it's like you know people
don't
the weird part for me was like people
didn't even know i was a stand-up right
you know they're just like and you were
playing a stand-up no no i don't even
talk about that [ __ ] i'm talking about
workaholics right you know people were
like you know but but these are college
kids that got no money they don't know
how to go out they're not savvy like
that let's go
go out for a night out you know where
it's going to cost you 85
because of drinks and tickets and all
that you know so i didn't have an
audience like that i didn't you know and
uh so then it's like now
you know you do a podcast that just does
more for
you know selling tickets than you know
so it's i don't know what it is maybe
like you said it's a culmination of
things so
now it's gonna be like oh that's the guy
from work of hogs and i'm dying up here
and
oh he had that special i saw oh yeah got
this podcast oh he's got you know what
all the connections have to be made yeah
yeah and all synapses firing and boom
well i think especially gonna be great i
love the trailer i haven't seen it yet
um
so i i'ma watch it you know just so you
know i hope it does i hope it is one of
those things where people like who's
that guy
right right people act like you just
started doing comedy yeah no
it's funny because it's not if you're
not a big comic people don't know you
anyway that's why i don't think feel
like i made it like
there's here are several instances where
you know
you you haven't made it like one of them
is where
like a friend will introduce me to a
friend of theirs
and ask you what you're doing you say
i'm a comic oh yeah have you been on tv
yet
and it's like me and you just spent the
first half of this talking about
my tv credits yeah yeah yeah yeah now i
guess yeah you see me sometimes
brother and then so then that's then you
know you haven't made it because
people you just told somebody your name
yeah and they
have no inkling here's one for you
here's
this is quick i'm not gonna because i
talked about this on what i would
with gary when he was on but like i was
out in oxnard at the uh
i just was out in oxnard because my
parents lived there and i went over to
the the club it was right next it's next
door actually
you know and sean williams was uh there
so i walked to the green room to knock
on the door two security guards like
oh [ __ ] what you doing here you know
they really they were like gonna
attack me and be like get back and i
said to the dude i was like
i i'm not trying to be like you should
know who i am
guy but like really
you know what i mean like you know
nothing connects you know and i know i'm
gonna end up i
i think i'm scheduled to headline that
club yeah and believe me i'm gonna be
talking about this
on stage which is hilarious so it's like
that's what i mean so that's
the moment where i was like oh i i
haven't made it right you know what i
mean and i have one similar to that in
times square
they have barkers for this comedy club
called laugh
and they have a clipboard with pictures
of comics and they try to get tourists
yes yes and when i'm walking by those
bar because
they hit me up like i'm a tourist and
like hey got a great comedy show
yeah great comics and you should come in
and have a great time they didn't
recognize that i was a comedy yeah yeah
yeah and i was like man i got to work
hard
that happens to me too the guy's like
you know hey you wanna come to the show
i said i'm looking at this guy
and you because then what pisses me off
is she was like that person's a comic
yeah and they don't even like you're a
comic yeah and you're looking at me and
so you don't
i go down like the security guard hasn't
made it all they work in the comments
they work
in the comic con they're there all the
time and they didn't recognize that you
were a cop
yeah i was like wow this is like so you
know you did you always had these
moments
and but those are the things that keep
you humble you know what i mean i think
that that's the kind of thing angry
well there's a fine line between uh
humbleness and angriness right
mm-hmm yeah i don't know it's
just a weird business but you also like
ian also has a soccer podcast you know
yeah let's let's get those viewers
talk about a niche have you been
watching a women's world cup yeah i just
watched the finals this morning i landed
vegas usb netherlands oh wow 2-1
it's good to know that one u.s it's good
to know that something in the united
states
is dominating in that sport because i
[ __ ] hate that
we're not great at soccer why because we
have
300 plus million people just by sheer
numbers
we should have the better soccer players
we should have the better athletes our
basketball players are better
our football players are better you know
that doesn't mean that
listen this is this is why you just
asked me
who won right u.s one you didn't even
know i didn't know i wasn't paying
attention but that's the thing like this
is how i know soccer's not big and i
said this on my
instagram today like i'm standing
outside
the bar where the game we watched the
game was packed in there
people are cheering but i knew as soon
as they gave him the trophy
and everybody walked out the bar they
were going to go about this day
as if it was a normal day yeah if this
some other country won a world cup
[ __ ] you it's no working for
two weeks every this was like you're
driving down the street
in traffic people are partying right now
like i got here
easily there's no one honking their horn
there's no flag out the window yeah
nobody's doing it there's no flares
going off
like july 4th like this fireworks all
day
right you just don't think soccer is
gonna ever really blow up in there
we're not gonna win until it's like that
yeah you know what i mean yeah until
it's like that yeah people somebody
brought a drum set to the bar
and they boom boom boom boom boom boom
but as soon as they won
it was the karaoke contest started
yeah like in other places people are
like
and they're making babies right now you
know what i'm saying that like they're
so overcome with emotion yeah that it
takes
a week or two for it to drain out of
them the euphoria
from winning it and then so we have to
get that
are you are you that crazy are you upset
about that where america's not that
crazy about soccer yeah
i think the part of the problem is when
the soccer season is
for young people right that's what i
think and the main thing is like soccer
in the states happens at the same time
as baseball track and basketball
well that's what's going on right now no
no no i'm talking about in high school
the high school seasons in the united
states
when those sports happen they coincide
with each other you know
so then soccer's they're the last one
they're not getting necessarily
the best athletes at these schools
especially in the rural areas
you know people want to play like you
know the white kids are still trying to
play baseball
and like you know and i even think i'm
not sure when the hockey season is but
that to me is the problem with soccer
they need to move it
well there is a league now mls
la has one of the best teams two of the
best teams right
yeah i guess two but you know i'm an
lafc
lover you know and a part of
what you like when we were in high
school if you played soccer
you'd be like this is over after high
school or maybe college but there's no
future in it
right so then but now you can
there's a league there's some way for
you to go if you want to take it further
so i think that killed not having
it's like having an erection but no
girlfriend no place to put it no place
to put it
you're like why even having an erection
i know your hands are tied yeah yeah
you know but now you're like you see all
right if i have an erection i can put it
somewhere
you you're like you'll have your
erection but i still think that the
appeal
of basketball baseball and track and
field it's more glamorous
it's more glamorous to to even if it's
not even about
what you're going to do after it's still
in high school
soccer's not a it wasn't it doesn't but
that's not bad we'll just get the people
who really want to play soccer but
they're not the better athletes
is the problem yes at some point like
listen the whole
country has to grow as a soccer nation
not just
the players yeah yeah for us to win the
world i got you about it
everybody's thinking it's a team-based
thing no it's a whole
right it's a country evolution that has
to take place as a country
that will nurture the players the right
atmosphere the right temperature
everything
every piece of seasoning is right and
then boom you know you taste like
this is delicious party well if you look
at baseball like baseball
suffering getting the the the black
athlete
because and i believe that is partly the
fault of major league baseball
i think they should have um they should
have put more money
into urban communities rural communities
that you know like
underprivileged community to so they
could play baseball because these are
going to be the baseball players that
are going to be 20 years later if you
look at the sport now i mean there are
not that many
uh black babies black baseball players
and i think that's because of that you
know because there's
you know baseball is a lot you are so
boring you need 18 people
you need you know you got to have
equipment you have to have like you know
if the
local park is a piece of [ __ ] like what
are you gonna do you know people just
gravitate towards playing basketball
towards you know
the these other sports because so i
think that
what you're saying is true when you talk
about a nation if we're gonna
if people really wanna play soccer then
we gotta start making it a priority we
got to start like
providing places for kids to play soccer
yeah yeah for sure you know what i mean
especially like the the upper echelon
type kids that are going to be the
athletes of tomorrow
yeah as an adult in california whenever
i wanted to play soccer
i had a crew of dudes we used to play
with but
as whenever we went on some field they
would just kick us off
yeah yeah and it's like you have to take
up so much of the field for this [ __ ]
sport or even if we didn't take up a lot
they're like this is not
for soccer and they sh we get shunned so
many places
this is see this is what i'm talking
about there's nothing
like so some kid walking by couldn't see
us playing and be inspired because
right we couldn't even play you couldn't
even play yeah you know so that's
that but that's like indicative of like
you know that's a trickle down of like
or a trickle up really of like this is
why we're not doing this right but
there's
basketball courts everywhere anybody can
play yeah all you need is two people you
don't even need two people you could be
out there shooting on your own exactly
you know what i mean so that's why
but i do think that's the the thing with
that so maybe did you see you played
soccer in jamaica
was that the thing england jamaica and
new york and in california
i played with these guys some of them
were like
french english and they were all worked
behind the scenes in entertainment
like some of them were cameraman i
played with a dp that did black panther
not black panther like pink panther
right like i played with some
people one one guy he created uh
not what's the slam dance right
like his name is peter i forgot peter's
like follow him on instagram like
like slam dances produce like a lot of
great movies and documentaries and
that's just like we just i don't know
how i met these guys somebody told me
they played soccer at this job that i
worked and he said
meet them there and i met them and for
years i just played with these guys
after that
it was like the best time of my life
yeah i played i played i stopped playing
basketball
when one i got like fat
but really it was like you shouldn't
have stopped i know but i remember i
know but no but what really happened was
when i was like
26 i was out at the dunk courts we
called them you know because they had
the rims lower
you know what i mean so like so there's
grammar schools and stuff like that the
rims would be like
when i was a kid i used to think why
would you want to play it but now i got
it
because he was like you know we thought
we was like michael jordan and [ __ ] out
there dunking on everybody but i got
some this guy kicked me because i used
to be talk [ __ ] i was like shaq out
there
i used to have hops man and then like uh
then i tore my acl and i was down and
out for like a year
because i didn't have insurance so i had
to get on my mom's insurance so i can
get to
surgery so it was like a two three year
period where i just
wasn't active anymore but you know from
26 to like you know whatever and then
you know
gotta you know i had my girlfriend and i
just like you know i just got lazy i had
to work
it was like i just got fat and then i
was like trying to as you get older it's
harder to get that [ __ ] off
you know so then and then i still trying
to play basketball but when you're older
when you're in your 30s
trying to play basketball and you're not
normally active man
the stretching is like you're supposed
to stretch i popped my i think i had a
kevin durant uh
injury my [ __ ] calf i turned around
like did somebody kick me
because it just something happened so
then it just was like oh this is too
much it's too dangerous
for me to be out here playing yeah yeah
i i feel like that too like that's why i
stopped playing soccer i was like
i got this one injury and nothing
happened there was no collision
nothing and it was just no real injury
yeah man
and i was like i can't do that i can't
exactly yeah
i remember one time i was out playing at
the courts with my buddies
and my friend like it was like a just
dangerous backboard okay it was just a
mess yeah it was dangerous because it
was too low
he went up and uh he hit his side of his
face on the backboard like
god like this right and everybody was
like oh [ __ ] he fell down
then he got up and he was like oh man
you know and everybody was like
panicking
you know everybody was like they were
just like whoa it would look bad
so he goes hey eric you know
can you look so i i i
his dude his nose like his nose was
coming off his face
okay like but he didn't feel it yet
so i went like i had to go like this i
was like
you know i got to go no i said i said
you know what
just to be cautious we should probably
go to the emergency room
let's get him to the emergency room just
you know what i mean i was trying not to
because i wanted to be like your [ __ ]
nose is coming off your face you know
what i mean
but like i just i knew not to panic this
dude we had to climb a fence and [ __ ]
like that yeah we had to climb fences
yeah and that was another thing too
where i was like i'm 37 whatever it was
i'm not climbing a fence to go play
basketball
and i don't want to pay him be in some
under 40 league or whatever those type
of shits you know
but like that's when that was one of the
last times i was like i think i'm good
that he stopped when did he start
feeling the pain well he took him
because i didn't go with them to the
hospital but he told me later
he said the doctor said if he didn't
come in
when they did it would have been more
serious where they would have had to
like he
just the type of surgery and he could
have lost part of his nose
stuff like that so it was i was just
like oh [ __ ] you know i was like that
could happen at any time yeah anytime
you get like a little like i sprained my
ankle now and i'm like god i'm down and
out and
then you then you start to notice it
because you walking on stage yeah
yeah you know what i mean so i was like
i'm too old to be doing this [ __ ] but um
ian we've been talking for [ __ ] [ __ ]
ton of time so
um this is my guy ian edwards let's go
over it again
ian billboard edwards if you've been
wondering who the [ __ ] that is
on these billboards around town because
i know that's your question who the [ __ ]
is that i mean it might be you don't
have to put it like that though
i mean it says my name on it you just
read it a little bit yeah
just read it a little bit yeah but they
can't get it they can't get to the name
because they like you know
they but anyway no i'm just teasing it's
great uh so he's got a special coming
out ian talk
he's coming on comedy central uh july
12th i'm not sure when this is going to
air because what's the date right now
seven july seven oh it's for sure gonna
be this is gonna be
after i'll figure maybe i'll do a
special maybe this was a special
mid-week episode of we're from mcgriff
maybe i'll do that uh
so if i did that then great if i didn't
do that make sure you go
try to find ian's uh special um but this
is my guy ian that was all his
information is gonna be
on the uh underneath on the description
and uh
you know thanks for coming on oh my
pleasure thanks for having me man
it's my man like homie uh for real one
of
my best friends in the whole wide world
uh thank you yeah thanks for watching
we're from griffin make sure you hit the
subscribe make sure you hit the like and
once again make sure you follow in all
his links are going to be down right
down there so make sure you watch that
and i'll catch you guys next week
[Music]
i'm